[Music]  I'm gonna have to ask you to leave  Chris Harrison speaks out about bachelor  in paradise scandal after production was  halted over allegations of misconduct  between cast mates Corrine elympios and  Demario Jackson so I'm really going to  need you to get the while a source told  et on Monday the ABC show is in danger  of being done Chris is optimistic that  filming will resume as planned the TV  host said in a statement to ABC News  quote it is my sincere hope that we can  come to a quick resolution on this and  get back to work  very soon still no word on the fate of  the hit show following the alleged  incident the fourth season of bachelor  in paradise was set to premiere on  August 8  [Music]